previously ungrounded God I hope I'm
recording it says I am I see audio I see
I hope it's a nebulous thing of whether
or not uh Wade is in fact recording When
did the term Grizzlies become a thing no
idea and I hate it what is that it means
hot dogs hi oh we were in human shaped
foam cutouts I love that person this
hole was made for me
yeah we lived on a base yeah something
like that guys we've gotten as far as we
did back down this must be where we
should live
oh
no I'm very impressionable I don't see
any spiders oh good okay
I'm ready to eat my pillow I'm so tired
I'm ready to eat my pillow I'm so tired
as soon as this meat's done cooking I
will hop in oh I'm ready to eat my
pillow I'm so tired broken jokes
what Oh I thought it was oh my God I
thought I was just advancing the okay
well you're not here for this oh what in
the hell are you doing I pushed one
button
[Music]
oh geez hey guys I might be dead you're
okay okay I guess
oh look out for those leaves oh [ __ ]
what did you do two spiders that were
over there yeah
hopefully that exploded some spiders
what did you do you're gonna be in so
much trouble uh nothing wasn't me must
have been someone else rotten larva
blade yeah I got that
that was mine what in the hell was it
whoa I gotta analyze it okay I have to
analyze it whoa I found another science
uh science building oh cool okay this is
perfect there was more than one how you
guys doing on food so you want me to
bring you some food
I'm okay at the moment I'm analyzing
I'm gonna come over where you boys are
whoa we can now make this
oh cool oh hey I found your mites you
needed to kill mites right I was just
looking for fuzz yeah my fuzz if it was
available
you hear that loud noise yeah the like
rumbly crunchy sound yeah what was that
oh
still happening oh I found grub Heaven
it's in a tunnel I could go in it but I
won't look at the sap oh yeah oh yeah
you found a nice sap sack oh God and I
thought you were a spider you scared me
so much
hey did you guys know you could block
yeah hey Mark I found your science
building yeah pretty cool right it's
offline are you did you use this one
already I used no I used one
I don't use all of it maybe you're not
worth it I got I can handle myself
okay I got 13 fuzz if you need them yeah
I got a good amount I forget what four I
was just like I knew I didn't have fuzz
Tremor detected boys I don't know what
that means I don't see what
holy [ __ ] what are you
oh it's a stick bug
peep a creature oh it's coming what is
the paper is a device of some sort I
don't remember what it is I think we
need to investigate the science thing
God there's so many things that we need
to do whoa
God and you I found it yeah you
literally intercepted it from chasing me
I think
Aaron hey what's up man hey what's up
man you want to kill it I don't know if
we're ready but we can try uh Maybe not
maybe not Maybe not maybe don't worry
guys I'm here to help all right cool
um I'm gonna go back to grubhaven unless
you guys killed all the grubs
I didn't kill any grubs I'm gonna go
back to Grub heaven
oh that's that's a big oh my God that's
so much larger the Jesus holy [ __ ] yeah
I'll grab Heaven Mark you having a good
time they're not grubs it's not grubs oh
okay you might think it's grubs it's not
grubs I did think it was grubs because
of how you said that but now I'm not
thinking in Scrubs as much it's not
grubs how's heaven
that was kind of boring actually it's
weird it looks a lot like heaven is a
place on Earth well actually it's a
place here up in uh is this not on Earth
uh well no I don't know what do I know I
thought we were on Earth no no yes maybe
Delirious from the the venom coursing
through my veins oh poison that's funny
yeah that one one of you guys discovered
something and left some purple behind
what is this
I would never leave some purple behind
oh yeah the song it's building right
next to the raw science
yay whoa I found a weed stem you're
discovering so many things Mark yeah
well you guys gotta catch up
you got weed still got a genius over
here yeah I'll go analyze it I'll
analyze it so smart no recipes
discovered but I analyzed
oh yeah look at this analyzing Wham look
at all these oh look at all these
freaking things I discovered God my
brain oh here goes another one
liquid rage oh okay you guys see in the
liquid rage
no oh God yeah
there it is yep that's it that's the one
oh oops
that's what P does p does it you caught
me mid throw I was just in the throes of
Rage why is it when I hit peace those
other players aren't ready when you guys
hit P it just stops me in the middle of
everything well that's that's on you man
bologna and cheese let me try it again
oh look at that it works it works got it
it works so crazy can't believe it
[Applause]
it was just a grub it was just grub oh
thank God for you oh God why is my
inventory always perpetually full how do
we make clay oh grubs have two different
things my inventory is awful I guess we
don't have the ability to know about
clay yet I've already done it
uh how do we how do we get clay where is
Clay so I found it like a Red Rock of
clay in like a little pool of water
um
yeah
and you have to have a shovel to get oh
God
uh Bob are you by the house
yes come back oh take that this doesn't
I was gonna show you where I got the
clay but it doesn't really tell you
anything because it looks just like a
normal pool of water right now
oh God I got stunned
foreign
looking my advice meter and it says
don't get stunned
I will pass that advice on to you
hear that Mark about the not getting
stunts I see I see interesting
interesting
oh god oh no I was so close oh I choked
it I choked oh I'm choking don't worry
Mark I will save you oh I'm so tired I
could eat my pillow oh man
that that doesn't make any sense when
you get knocked down I don't know about
you guys but I'm so tired I can eat my
Bella or whatever it is oh Max is very
adamant about eating his pillow this
dude is just into eating his pillow he's
like I'm starting to think it's a fetish
no little help here oh I'm on the way
buddy don't you worry about it yeah uh
Lexi and put in the Sonic drowning sound
[Music]
I'm so close wait a second no oh you got
me oh my God
holy [ __ ] it was it literally was double
zero good the car was empty on my screen
that says that's good that's finishing
up man all right I'm gonna finish this
thing oh wait I'm
ow oh God yeah
yeah there we go
there's the larva die all right I need a
bandage oh you need the fuzz stuff I'm
about to have a whole shitload of it
he's [ __ ] fast oh I'm about to be
dead uh we're coming hey stink bug
friend we're coming Bob
hello he said stink bug I don't know if
we are we're coming Bob maybe we should
rethink no no it's fine the stink bug's
totally not chasing me oh the mites are
chasing you though yeah they're
Relentless these tiny baby stink bugs
giving you trouble here Bob
I don't even see a stink bug
oh hey look that thing I'm not looking
in the right direction no you're not
holy [ __ ] oh oh oh I'm stuck in Grass
cage okay why are you on me that's not
good are we doing this are we doing this
are we doing this I why would we do this
oh it's radioactive
oh sweet Jesus oh my God I think the
Green Cloud meant I don't know could
have been good like health or something
Mark you're down in a cloud of toxic gas
I noticed wait wait wait hey it's going
away it's clear it's clear I think uh
why don't we just go home
yeah
let's go
yeah yeah usually screaming stops
everything's good
I know right here
hey guys you know you know what he can't
do what he can't go up on rocks ah good
good
oh he can fart around rocks though he's
probably fine oh hey an old hot dog a
Glizzy if you will what is a Glizzy
where'd that come from I don't know Bob
said it you like glizzies
[Laughter]
I thought it was a glissmeister with no
hell that was really Brave of being a
test and see if that was a grub or a
larva Really Brave yeah
I like listening
whoa no way here there are magical
attacking stingford holy [ __ ] this is
incredible that is just the right voice
in every way for a magical stocking
stink bug every time I do that voice gar
laughs no matter the context he could be
at a funeral like crying over a lost
loved one and I'd be like hey it's your
grandparently
uh I have one of those bits
okay that hurts
[Laughter]
oh good all right Mark what's your
magical voice you could do I don't think
I have one guys I think I just I'm the
one that laughs you guys do the voice
myself that's all it is there's always
two jokers and one laugher for every
good Trio yeah that's it that's how it
works
I'm the Jimmy Fallon of the group they
have many people have said this
[Laughter]
every bit Mark is standing in the back
laughing like a jerk yeah exactly oh I
hope that wasn't poisonous huh what was
poisonous I ate food that made my screen
turn red when I ate it oh that means
it's real good yeah it means it's extra
cool oh okay good yeah
I didn't nobody makes me laugh the way I
do that's true that's fair somebody
makes me laugh my own laugh oh man
slowly there was another place where
people could get this hilarious uh kind
of humor they can 24 7. what
it's as accessible as single people
distractible is I don't know if that was
a compliment but that's what I said yeah
I don't know what that meant either but
I'm intrigued I'm enticed yeah I know go
on go on oh it's a podcast it's called
distractible go go now hurry uh
sense of urgency is outrageous quick the
podcast is burning down
[Laughter]
[Applause]
go to the link in the description below
oh God there's a stink bug here if I
don't go yeah I'm gonna stink in there
all right
[Music]
it's stink bug now stink bug home
invasion is a serious issue you need to
know some boundaries man
why does anybody listen to us I don't
know I asked that a lot I also do that
actually it is weird Bob your character
does sound like that
oh yeah that the weasel is it the Weevil
doing it or is it you it's the it's the
weevils doing the little Grunts and
stuff never mind guys just walking
around just like
where also do we get thistle needle
because if we could make bow and we
could make arrows for bows if we did
that I think we're supposed to
investigate the explosion oh right and I
gotta peep a creature I got a peep of
creed hey guys hit x x what what Matt
marker placed
all I did
how's it going
did you know I see you hit that creature
with X that means to press X the beep oh
man Jesus Mark I'm peeping you
oh wait a minute oh no
I I think he sees me oh
my God
oh God yeah wait where is he where's
Wade let's beep him don't put your peeps
down people actively don't worry you're
becoming non-stop oh I'm trying to Peep
and eighth do you peep him right over
that Ridge
God
do you think
I can't get that close that's not how
peeping works oh wow I'm gonna there you
go that's good that's good and I'm going
in for a close-up I'm going to try to
peep closer
oh
moving in Captain why are you guys doing
the Oompa Loompa dance
are you getting a load of this hey guys
[Music]
what are you peeping down there oh hey
how you doing wait turn to me
the [ __ ] slow turn
okay okay I'm done vaping you peep each
other for a minute
uh well good news guys they can't eat
the food in the basket sick sick I see
what you're doing I see what you're
getting at Max yeah where the [ __ ] is
Clay I've only found the one yeah we're
gonna we're gonna need clay if we want
to have vertical uh expansion which I
know we do it would be like in uh by
water right yeah the only one I found
was like in a little pool of water right
by our house and I was like oh all these
little pools of water might have Clay
not a single [ __ ] one does I'm all
geared up I don't care wow Jesus Christ
have you guys studied uh no I don't
think you have there's no way philosophy
yes no nobody ever wants to hear about
that except on our podcast where people
always seem to really like when you talk
philosophy
yeah
so you know maybe people should check
that out maybe how did I leave a marker
on the ground and why is there a marker
you peeped it
what is happening stink bug woke up I
don't sweat
how do I get rid of this marker
uh open the map and hit r
God I just like the way you said R I
wasn't sure but I'm I committed oh we
need mushrooms where's mushrooms they're
under the big mushrooms you know okay
okay okay okay
weevoo
why is there a spider out here spider
yeah
uh why do you sound like a nerd
you're a nerd okay
so yeah it's
I'm sorry what was that
oh my God please don't
good God that was scary I am being
poisoned actively and I my health is
falling and I'm dead
holy crap that guy just was unrelenting
I'll save you okay
please do I have so much stuff kind of
on my way but I don't have a torch so
it's really dark and scary yeah that
dark yeah it's gonna be more dark soon
are you down in this creepy spider yes I
am no this is where we came from the
cases over here just so that's why I was
especially surprised that there was a
spider around here thank you Hoops hey
I'm glad I came to help thanks uh man it
sure is dark what do you need mushrooms
for uh because we have not analyzed
mushroom slurry oh I cannot craft
mushroom slurry uh yeah I don't have
mushrooms I have mushrooms I just can't
you need a cooking something oh there's
a symbol next to it you need a cooking
oh you probably need like a grinder
grinder it says grinder yeah we need a
grinder
oh really
uh I don't know why that made me laugh
my voice
we need a grinder
I weighed last at that
oh
God this is horrible hey guys he can't
climb up here probably if I give up I'm
gonna respawn in my thing which is right
here
I gave up no no no no no no okay no it's
fine because I respawn right here
great look I'm right here
okay well I'm going to stab him ah die
spider come here die spiders
die die
oh my God it has Health out there I'm
giving up there's no way I'm giving up
there oh God
I'm gonna grab my backpack and then I'm
gonna go up top oh my backpack
I'm down in the doorway help me
I got you just be right around
what do we do oh God just hide just hide
just hold your breath and hide
hey Mark's right here oh [ __ ] did it
leave I think it left
oh my God why was that at the base I
don't know because we don't have any
walls because we haven't been getting
walls that thing would not give a [ __ ]
about a wall of grass I'm gonna peep
this creature got it oh guys come back
guys
oh God oh God oh it's right there it's
right there to you oh it's right there
oh God
[Music]
hi what's up Triad spider how you doing
what's up all right if we coordinate it
if we let it go away a little bit and we
coordinate it and we run and sleep yeah
yeah I'm gonna go for the No No wait
it's going for them
all right hang on hang on everyone group
Up Wait group up
and sneak sneeze oh I'm so tired I could
eat my pillow
[Music]
sleep for eight hours oh I can eat my
pillow oh my God
hey I'm gonna wake up but he's just
standing there like I wake up
I can't sleep forever maybe we should
build a base ah maybe I'm I'm making
planks somebody else forming this bad
boy
huh I'm stinking I'm stanking planks
like a madman you're in charge
of what um build some walls and stuff
yeah forming it up all right excellent
excellent yeah yeah I believe we believe
in you I'm glad Mark believes we believe
in you
oh we can make sketches uh clay ramp oh
so much good stuff uh we need weed stems
where's weed stems at well we found him
over in the acorn area wait no they're
right here the dandelions are also weeds
oh okay all right we got weed stems it's
our priority today while it's early to
get walls up or do we want to go
investigate that explosion at the tree
uh two can do the building one can
explore I suppose we've all been to the
building right so I don't think it
matters I haven't actually seen it but
like you can go to it then yeah Bob you
go we'll take care of the base when you
get back this is gonna be oh it's gonna
be so good I'm gonna put my inventory in
the basket by the workbench so there's
plenty make sure you have a hammer and
shovel for grubs and acorns too while
you're over there I do I do like can't
we equip a dandelion tuft to like help
us fall slower yes uh oh can you yes oh
push the Glide button what is the Glide
button oh I think it's left shift
because whenever I equipped this tuft on
the bottom right it says left shift hey
look at me I'm glad wow
yeah it's left I didn't look at all all
right Fellers I'm out of here all right
best of luck God speed it's toward the
tree right it is the tree where is the
tree if you can't find the tree you're
going to die but I wish you luck all
right where do we want the door in our
walls at huh it seems like it's up to
you Foreman yeah Foreman
holy [ __ ] all right just make sure it's
a raised platform that we can defend
well the initial door is not but we can
raise it after uh-huh all right what do
we need oh okay sturdy door
I was just encircling the base we
already have are we building a new one
from scratch yeah probably I don't know
okay I can scrap this oh oh no it's fine
we're fine there we go I broke it back
down so we can do a race platform uh I
mean
I don't know do we have Clay I've got a
little bit but we need to find a lot
more I'm just gonna focus on getting
more weed stems for construction because
who knows how many we'll need oh my God
there's so many acorns fillers yeah this
area is great I love it nothing bad is
happening at all good he doesn't know he
doesn't know what don't I know what and
it didn't say anything we said we wish
it snowed oh me too that'd be cool
better how big snowflakes would look oh
that'd be so cool he's going to die but
look out for a fly yeah fly they're very
valuable wow okay yeah no I could I'll
look out I'll keep thanks for the tip oh
guys I found an entrance to a laboratory
oh you know what would have made this
bit way funnier
oh guys I found an entrance to a
laboratory
oh I really missed that opportunity yeah
you know you're right about that one
you're right about that one uh all right
keep us updated on anything okay all
right over and I heard you like you were
right next to me somehow
sorry is this better
how about about the salvos
is that good
that sounds fantastic thanks
[Applause]
if I adjust the machine to account for
their existence it should be the key to
the dish drinking uh expanding process
Miracle please bring up the readings for
The Irregular covalent snpi42z particle
traces science words that name is going
to get tiresome
build here and then we build out onto
the platform I love it
love it
terrorization
uh base camp I'm seeing a video feed
that says hostile presence is detected
[Applause]
people 27
no that is a negative that is not a
referring to a hostile that stands for
happy oh so so tasty I like eating
yep uh sounds like your battery's here
walking might be dying uh sorry just
change that out there I apologize but
yeah just uh go get yourself a snack
where that hostile
uh today is
over you know what that wasn't a better
bit I addressed my earlier statement
we're full of great bits what do you
mean guys I'm helping burgle whoa who's
burgle oh my goodness I don't know but
he could use a hand here you don't need
clay just build on the thing right you
have to build foundations on these oh
God my gosh she's so cute guys
oh God
I'm Bubba Bubba burgle well we had
enough clay for this one Foundation uh I
think you can use the science things to
look where resources are nearby I think
there's a scanner but it needs to have
juices juices what do you mean juices it
needs to have power or something what
how's it unpowered there's so much power
here I don't know man how is there no
power
I don't know man all right fine there's
got to be something else here that
offers clay clay play play no not clay I
lied okay I was really excited like oh
where but then you let me down and
that's what happened I just described it
to you back
okay the people at home needed to hear
that yes play-by-play of what literally
just transpired their attention spans
not too good clay
found clay
okay was it like in a pool of water yeah
it was yeah yeah we're gonna come toward
you and see if we can find even more of
it because we're gonna need a bunch it
takes four pieces for One Foundation
yeah look on your map for um
pieces of water and that'll that'll
really tell you where the clay is
there's some like extreme water east of
you and Northwest
extreme water I'm gonna leave that to
you I'm Gonna Keep building over here
okay you've got the clay all right I got
it don't worry I also found thistle
um
it's uh thorny plant it's just like
literally you see spiky leaves on a
plant that's a Thistle and you're gonna
find thistle all over it oh my God so
many arrows gonna have so many arrows I
can't wait till you say that about clay
so much clay so much clay well no I
don't
you you will I don't know if I will man
I don't I don't see clay anywhere here
you will but I I don't think I will no
no please I don't know why it's not a
police I've got everything I own on this
well you'll find it very irresponsible
yes guys we need to find the memory
chips and the other Laboratories no I'm
sorry memory chips the burger is broken
and he needs his brains back and they're
in memory chips and there are other
Laboratories we need to explore in the
backyard and give them his chips back so
they have Clay many more Labs many more
Labs okay what about many more clay I'm
sure you'll be able to find clay the
labs are what's really important this
really sounds like a fake whoa It's a
tiny spider what are you oh
I'm peeping I peeped spiderling
scary
whoa
I'm hearing strange noises
hey oh God it's a big sleeping wolf
spider I found the wolf spider nest why
did I find that is it guarding clay no
it's not
oh it's just a larva it's okay
oh
oh my God I found clay I found so much
clay I found more clay than I could ever
hope to have there's literally unlimited
amount of clay where I am it is exactly
as your dream mark open your map and hit
R opening my map and hit r
that puts a mark where you are oh hey
it's that big body of water I was
thinking that might have Clay yeah
excellent it did it does
but we need so much of it I hope you
have lots of inventory space I am so
full up
you will need to come here
I I found the other thing Burger gave us
is a computer that we can get more
quests from for questings questings
I'm registering my Biometrics right now
so I can access the quest tutor
you can buy stuff with your science
money
we have a lot of science money smithing
station whoa
whoa [ __ ] 101 you could buy a cookery
multi-story bases whoa
you got all that I don't have it it
costs science we have 1790 science
multi-story basis cost is a thousand
Costas oh it says I should get smithing
station and cooking 101. well who needs
cookie we have food we're not worried
about food dude Wade Ives getting so
much clay
you don't understand try to come help
you no I'm getting multi-story basis
guys all of your work to find the clay
is going to be mood
all right or should I get fortified
bases maybe you should not come back you
know with that attitude I'm saying maybe
you should suck this work word whoa okay
uh I don't have any food I'm real hungry
oh I know I just said we had food but we
don't I don't anyway I'm gonna eat raw
food I'm eating raw I'm eating it raw
raw food all right I got the food one oh
I've got no food I eat bad food I don't
feel good guys we've got questuses
that give us science and reward we need
to haunt
weevils we need to oh my God he's taking
a [ __ ] behind me really loudly who is
this all right the robot is
wow that's a that's a really Advanced
robot I accepted three quests I don't
know how you see them I see find the
grave robbery burgle chip why do we need
to rob a grave couldn't tell you all
right I have a lot of clay I almost have
50. I'm gonna come back with it cool yes
all right hopefully that's enough how
many months I expanded things after you
said you found a limitless supply of
clay I explored the laboratory oh good
job come back home to us I'm sure I'll
make it home with no extraordinarily
terrifying circumstances I found another
Science Station oh that's good
oh yeah um were there more stems around
here or do I need to go cut down some
more dandelions uh
uh public dagger Guild tube nice oh I
found a
cassette table these are stems when I've
come to a decision it's time to restart
spacer development
prominent may not believe in it but I
know its potential
I must figure out how to return shrunk
objects to their original size
the first step will be to address the
particle transcription errors it seems
almost certain that the irregularities
are responsible for the failure during
the demonstration
please bring up all the lab data about
the unknown particles
four hours what are the chances for Less
delivery estimate will be prepared in
two hours or less
a suspicious beginning
I'm I'm back home I got clay what do you
need I need all the clay oh my God Jesus
um I'll place the foundations if you
want to start putting it in okay I'm
gathering uh
weed stems on my way home okay thank you
because we need those right yeah
oh wait don't do this one there's one
don't all right
who's knocking at our door there's one
was one aphid that really wants in real
bad
[Music]
you need help I can't come in it says
occupied
oh no
[Applause]
there's three more over here whoops I
forgot how big I made this kind of a
plant in the way plants can be broken
are you guys making the new base way far
away from the old base yeah he he did uh
Wade this is the one plant that cannot
be broken
there's one plan that it doesn't even
say like you need a higher level there's
just it doesn't do it we just have a
permanent little ramp up I guess all
right we have a broken ramp up weed
stems uh Bob you like you like the
permanent ramp that's kind of nice yeah
hopefully none of the AI things know how
that works don't worry I'm putting up
walls oh okay
maybe if I can get out of this plant we
can't cut down that's really helpful
here maybe you should rotate it to the
correct orientation
uh uh Foreman Wade
well that's wrong
no no maybe we should build it you know
right there perfect
[Laughter]
[Music]
I can't wait I'll put my bed right here
where this plan is coming in oh it's
gonna be great oh yeah let me get my let
me get my sleeping Place yeah I gotta go
get that
I'll be right back we need stems and
grass oh you got it
yeah oh man this is gonna be so good
what am I holding what is this it's a
grass where did I get it
the grass
dibs on under the plant and
Bam we could be plant brothers or plant
Brothers
cute little beds look at that nestled in
there that's kind of nice hey look is it
perfect no did you put me in charge yes
do you get what you get yeah that's true
he is not wrong does anyone have any
white Mite fuzz
white sorry not fuzz I might have not
fuzz it's like white fuzz uh yes I've
got one Netflix Oh Perfect can I have it
yes it's in this tiny bag with the thing
of nat fuzz on it thank you thank you
thank you
I made a bow
that tastes really good
it's a bow I had an extra uh weed stem
thing did someone pick up a weed stem
off the ground uh a little while no oh
nice neuter dude oh excuse me sir nice
snooter dude oh it's a nice neuter nice
snooter neuter nice nudes dude nice
nudes God always really admired your
nudes I hate to say at all of our food
it seems to have spoiled that's
unfortunate but we have not analyzed it
I'm gonna go analyze it who knew spoiled
food could be so useful science
okay
[Applause]
raw meat or spoiled me
spoiled meat slurry that sounds really
the grinder yeah very dark in our house
it is our I wonder if that's anyone's
fault in particular you know we were
just laying the foundations when you got
back Bob so it's gonna be done when I
got back yeah we literally we started
laying the foundations when you left and
then we were still laying the
foundations when you got back it took us
the whole day to find clay oh hey and
it's
look at that now that we only I can't
get off of you
I was okay
well
those movies or something let's get that
right
let's get that oh you don't have to
build it we can move bam oh you're right
we could you're right nah nah I don't
see a way to build a roof yet we have
walls passages and support aren't there
aren't there Bruce sir no no way I have
to move these things one at a time
unbelievable oh my God you guys move
your beds already a grinder requires so
much crap well it's not complicated it's
complicated not not complicated it is
complicated making human connections I
don't know are you okay man it's not not
uncomplicated complicated oh God what's
happening well I'm gonna make a lamp but
you guys seem to have be having trouble
but it's okay I don't need to make a
lamp I'm relocating our food resources
yeah yeah God what did I do wrong
I don't know that's kind of a big
question yeah and looking around I
couldn't I can't imagine what you know
what I made a good base and we're safe
there and you're gonna love it I made a
lamb I made the cooking station wow oh
that's pretty neat yeah see ooh sconce
sconces bro dudes [ __ ] sconces look
at the sconce I like this game already
but I didn't even know there were
sconces look at this sconce just blomps
you guys are just relocating and then
left clicking and it places right yep
yep great what it says on the screen
what'd you do I don't know if you're not
relocate right click wait you can't
right click to cancel it or place it
somewhere no no I can I'm left clicking
to place it and then it's not placing
aha
it's blue
I see it come on little fella you can do
it I don't know why it goes so terribly
for you you get to sleep over here
there you go you move my bed
[Laughter]
you didn't know I did because I thought
I could this is quite a home guys it's
not a house it's a home can you go over
by the fire Bob it won't let me move it
no you get to sleep where I said it so
that's what you get that's your
punishment for having a broken asset
computer for some reason it's great stop
stepping where I'm trying to please
where are you trying to put it buddy
you're in here to be right here
oh okay okay
would you like me to move it for you
while you're moving it yeah
wait guys let me hey can you move your
[ __ ] out of my way
hang on let me just come on now three
two one plop oh hey Wade did it
we just have to all touch Wade's things
and then he can use them oh let me help
you let me help you out there yeah
Closer Closer yeah right there right
there you go there as soon as the blues
yeah remind it just it didn't go sorry
just didn't go man I have the touch
that's what I've learned today oh Wham
there you go close enough I don't even
care now oh here I'll fix it I'll fix it
no okay yes but I don't know sure maybe
no please okay don't worry don't worry
fine
it's fun oh wait it's in place uh hey if
don't you love the natural cover we have
from this unbreakable stem yes yes it
feels it feels so secure you know yeah
hey that oh turn it down okay there we
go
around with my airbow and arrow I think
my ax well
all right so that's more clay do you
have mark huh I got uh about eight
pieces let's not gonna expand this
further if we need to but we can do it
later we got so much space we have so
much room for activities yeah what more
can we do oh I fell what more could we
want I don't know we need to build a
smithing station huh we do but we do
hey look I made more room for activities
wow good
hey look guys
it's home
oh
anyone else really hungry
all right buddy I say in-game or in real
life but all I can say is
yeah Aggie sometimes I I ghee or in real
life
uh in real life yeah you guys want to
save it and stop soon maybe oh yeah I
sure hope I have this footage we have
two or zero hours of recording to work
with how do you save this I hit escape
and click on Save probably oh hey kill
Weevil that's a quest we have I kill the
Weevil there's another Weevil stuck in
the geometry here but in jiggling around
yeah we can save and stop there
nice neuter dude nice neuter dude
yeah we have a house and a direction to
go in I think that's a good start I
think
I'll come back to base and make Bob save
again now you got the weevils all right
oh hey hello I don't know why the door
opening scared me all right so I hit
save again
excellent I'm so tired I could eat my
Billow if only this experience might be
ending portfolio in some way for people
to continue listening to our glorious
voices and conversations I can't think
of anything can you Bob
oh yes I can great
share it oh yeah okay sure yeah
it's even on my screen it's a podcast
starring three guys wait that's us whoa
there's three of them Mark oh Mark yeah
what I was giving everyone a chance to
do the
to say talk about the podcast oh
three of us are just naming only Mark
there's three of us there's more
oh oh I get it now there's uh
Wade Bob
that's really not what I had in mind
that's just how in sync we are what a
gorgeous like someone throws an idea and
we're just like let's do my idea no but
well Mark and I both thought you were
just naming us very slowly I think I was
handing it off all right whatever it's a
podcast all you have to do is you just
go to the to the
distractiblepodcastlike.com sort of
stuff and you know yeah well I listen to
it it's really good it's caused car
accidents
have you guys not read that on the
subreddit people saw a couple of people
were like I was listening while I was
driving and I almost crashed and one
person was like I did crash
no don't do that don't well yeah so if
you listen to the subreddit don't listen
to this while you're driving uh working
out in school at work dangerous tools or
machines or not yeah chopping with a
knife in the kitchen uh vacuuming
reloading guns on the potty not on the
potty while working as an electrician
without gloves on or with it's very
dangerous but that's just how good it is
well you're sitting alone in a padded
room turn this on all right that seems
fitting mark
signing off
[Music]